[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 5 juillet voici le programme
de ce soir après les émeutes de la
semaine dernière suite à la mort de Naël
durant un contrôle policier à Nanterre
les premières condames condamnations
tombent au tribunal de Versailles la
plupart des prévenus ont entre 18 et 22
ans et les peines prononcées sont
sévères ont fait le point en début
d'émission il est fin prêt pour
accueillir les joueurs du Paris
Saint-Germain le tout nouveau centre
d'entraînement situé à Poissy fait 74
hectares avec au total une dizaine de
terrain de football sur place également
des structures pour les plus jeunes nous
retrouvons sur place notre journaliste
Grégory canalet et dévoilée hier le
parcours des épreuves de cyclisme pour
les Jeux Olympiques de Paris 2024
passera dans les Yvelines les 180
cyclistes rouleront donc devant le
château de Versailles il traverseront
également la vallée de Chevreuse juste
après avoir fait au Vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines et on en parlera
avec notre consultant cyclisme Yann
Dujarier tout à l'heure et pour le
moment sur le plateau Olivier sevesuc
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes le
président de l'AS Poissy votre club
vient d'être exclu des championnats
nationaux par la DNCG la direction
nationale du contrôle de gestion de la
Fédération la raison une dette
avoisinant les 280 000 euros quel est
votre ressenti Olivier ses vésic après
cette exclusion dans un premier temps
comme cela fait 6 ans que j'ai le poste
de président vous pouvez imaginer je
suis très affecté après toutes les
toutes les campagnes que j'ai menées que
ce soit avec la N2 avec les jeunes avec
la section handicap tout ce que j'ai pu
faire le football féminin il y a eu un
certain nombre de paramètres qu'on fait
que je m'en suis assez expliqué je parle
en parler ce soir néanmoins je suis très
déçu et je vous remercie de me recevoir
parce que j'étais venu avec des
garanties et c'est là que le bablaise
j'étais venu avec des repreneurs
si vous voulez travailler avec moi ou
sans moi d'ailleurs néanmoins j'avais un
chèque de 220 000 et comme j'avais 80000
de réserve on arrivait à en arriver à
l'équilibre on pour pouvoir partir sur
une mouture qu'on avait travaillé
d'ailleurs j'avais gardé grand secret
sur cette opération personne n'était au
courant même pas dans trésorier c'était
d'une volonté de la cliente et puis je
suis venu également expert-comptable
cette fameuse personne qui voulait
prendre le club c'est société d'ailleurs
et puis et puis un avocat qui avait ce
compte en séquestre au nom de la laisse
Poissy mais qu'effectivement elle
voulait certaines garanties de rester
moyenne de ce qui était tout à fait
logique donc par rapport à la première
réunion que j'avais eu sur ce trou là
finalement il était comblé et j'étais
comblé et tout le monde était comblé en
fait c'est ça mais derrière ils m'ont
dit on est pressé enfin on va aller très
très vite sur le président bon j'ai
quand même je suis exprimé sur mon
parcours sportif et les actions sociales
que j'ai menées les Ukrainiens vous êtes
au courant je suis venu suffisamment sur
le plateau c'était pas pour me dédouer
c'était pour expliquer aussi les raisons
pour lesquelles on a eu quelques soucis
des sponsors qui sont partis un tas de
choses je me suis expliqué sur les 34000
euros il y a eu tellement de problèmes
qui ont été arrivés à 120 000 également
qui ne sont pas rentrés sur 280 faites
le calcul des primes de match pour
l'équipe première puisqu'on a gagné s'il
n'avait pas eu ces problèmes l'un des 7
ponts on aurait pu monter donc voilà
donc toute cette dynamique elle a
malheureusement tout a explosé et là je
suis extrêmement déçu j'ai fait une
longue interview à RMC aujourd'hui dans
le monde du sport en disant on a fait
des est-ce qu'ils sont là pour nous
aider quand on sait évidemment que ils
sont là abandonnés de déception je vous
propose d'en parler un peu plus en
détail tout à l'heure en face de vous
Elisabeth l'escouade bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes la directrice de la
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet ce
samedi 8 juillet aura lieu la grande
soirée de l'été à la Bergerie Nationale
de Rambouillet à quoi faut-il s'attendre
alors le festival de La Bergerie
nationale c'est une journée festive
autour d'animation et de concert et qui
est destiné à mettre en valeur le
patrimoine de la Bergerie Nationale donc
on en parlera également en détail tout à
l'heure vous serez accompagné de
Virginie aneta la responsable pôle
musique actuelle pour l'usine un chapeau
et enfin avec nous un plateau une
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
régénéralège bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde
avec vous on verra les informations à
retenir dans les Yvelines aujourd'hui ce
sera juste après les prévisions météo de
demain
[Musique]
matin nous devrions avoir un grand
soleil dans les Yvelines au niveau des
températures il fera 14 degrés à
Rambouillet et où dans 15 à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 16 à Versailles dans
l'après-midi le soleil sera toujours au
rendez-vous et côté température il fera
24 degrés en moyenne et demain nous
fêterons les mariésas le pont maintenant
sur les informations du jour à retenir
dans les Yvelines
et on commence ces informations du jour
Régine par la présidente de la région
Île-de-France Valérie Pécresse qui
appelle à la fermeté envers les casseurs
et les émeutiers ce matin Valérie
Pécresse donc la présidente de la région
Île-de-France l'une des régions les plus
touchée par les émeutes qui ont fait
suite à la mort de Naël s'est exprimée
sur RTL elle adressait un bilan des
dégâts sans bâtiments publics et
s'agacer saccager 39 bus de tramways et
400 au commerce détruits selon elle la
République doit sanctionner et
reconstruire je vous propose d'écouter
un extrait la moyenne d'âge des
personnes des centaines de personnes qui
ont été arrêtées c'est 17 ans le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons une
justice des mineurs qui n'est pas en
capacité de juger en comparaisse
immédiat très rapidement des mineurs on
n'est pas non plus on mesure de les
mettre hors d'état de nur c'est à dire
de les enfermer dans des endroits où ils
ne peuvent plus troubler l'ordre public
de les éloigner de leur quartier moi je
pense qu'il faut leur pourrir leurs
vacances je pense que tous ces casseurs
tous ces incendiaires il faut que on les
mette hors d'état de nuire
et dans cette interview également
Valérie Pécresse propose de doubler les
centres fermés pour mineurs sur le
territoire et de baisser la majorité
pénale à 16 ans et après les pillages du
Carrefour Market de Trappes des navettes
gratuites sont proposées pour pouvoir
faire ses courses et le magasin a ouvert
ses portes ce mardi avec des rayons
clairsemés des minibus sont proposés par
la ville aux habitants non véhiculés
pour leur permettre de se rendre dans
d'autres magasins plus éloignés le temps
que le Carrefour Market soit
complètement réapprovisionné et au
tribunal de Versailles les premières
condamnations sont tombées et
s'enchaînent oui des comparutions
immédiates ont député hier au tribunal
judiciaire de Versailles les prévenus
sont pour la plupart agés entre 17 ans
et 22 ans ils ont été interpellés pour
le pillage de magasins comme Darty à
plaisir ou encore à Buchelay selon la
procureur de la République Pauline
Patureau citée par nos confrères du 7 8
actu il n'y a aucun contrôle parental
certains des prévenus sont condamnés à
huit mois de dont d'autres seront jugés
plus tard en août ils sont pour
l'instant en détention provisoire et en
cours une peine de 10 ans
d'emprisonnement et toujours à propos
des émeutes régimes vous avez une bonne
nouvelle pour les usagers des transports
en commun tout à fait il de français
mobilité annonce que le trafic de
tramway et de bus reprendra normalement
sur tout le territoire selon Clément
beau ne le ministre des Transports des
dérogations localisés pourront tout de
même s'appliquer si il y a une situation
d'urgence on poursuit avec le chiffre du
jour Régine 1,5 pourquoi 1,5 milliards
d'euros c'est le montant que son gars
que s'engage à mobiliser le fs2i donc le
fond de solidarité est d'investissement
interdépartemental pour le développement
des infrastructures de transport
aujourd'hui les présidents de 7
départements en Île-de-France se sont
réunis pour lancer les négociations ils
attendent que les tailles que la région
Île-de-France formalisent dès que
possible les décisions direction La
Verrière le parking relais ouvre cet été
oui et il se entre les voies ferrées et
la venue Schuller 900 places seront
disponibles et le parking sera gratuit
pour les détenteurs d'un Pass Navigo qui
stationnent leur véhicule au moins 9
fois par mois l'objectif c'est
d'encourager les automobilistes à
privilégier les transports en commun et
on poursuit avec un mot de sport oui le
joueur de golf Antoine rosener s'est
qualifié hier pour le British Open
livinois s'était engagé sur le tournoi
du sandwich dans le dans le comté de
Kent en Angleterre il participera pour
la deuxième fois de sa carrière au
British Open et enfin le concours du
tremplin des voies revient pour une 9e
saison et si vous avez l'âme d'un
chanteur alors ce concours est fait pour
vous vous pouvez candidater dans trois
catégories interprète 17 ans et moins
interprète 18 ans et plus et auteur le
dépôt des candidatures est au vert
jusqu'au est ouvert jusqu'au 25 octobre
2023 pour s'inscrire il faut remplir un
formulaire sur le site sur le site
tremplin des voix.com et préparer une
bande démo
bien merci beaucoup Régine Radet pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
aujourd'hui le nouveau site
d'entraînement du Paris Saint-Germain a
été dévoilé à la presse située à Poissy
notre journaliste Grégory canalet était
sur place il nous livre quelques
précisions en plus de présenter son
nouvel entraîneur ce mercredi le Paris
Saint-Germain a également dévoilé sont
tout nouveau centre d'entraînement le
campus PSG qui est installé donc à
Poissy vous voyez derrière moi elle est
terrain de football il y en a en tout à
17 sur ce site installé dans les
Yvelines et les footballeurs du groupe
professionnel vont pouvoir fouler ses
terrains pour la reprise des
entraînements dès ce mois de juillet ils
seront rejoints en cours d'année par les
footballeuses de la section féminine
également les jeunes du centre de
formation ici à Poissy c'est un site de
74 hectares avec point d'orgue point
centrale le bâtiment des joueurs qu'on a
pu visiter en avant-première avec
différents espaces il y a notamment le
vestiaire un espace de musculation de
balnéothérapie l'espace de restauration
également les chambres
occupées par les joueurs il y en a en
tout 37 dans ce bâtiment ici à Poissy et
je vous le disais le Paris Saint-Germain
a poursuivi cette journée de mercredi en
présentant son nouvel entraîneur Louis
Enrique je suis vraiment ravi d'être là
du Paris Saint-Germain
ravier et j'ai très envie d'apprendre
une nouvelle langue de connaître une
ville merveilleuse et impayée incroyable
je suis vraiment très impatient très
enthousiaste autant moins que mon équipe
technique l'identité offensive c'est non
négociable si on ne pense pas qu'on peut
jouer de façon offensive on ne vient pas
moi c'est ma philosophie
comment entraîneur évidemment tu dois
t'adapter aux joueurs que tu as mon
travail en tant qu'entraîneur c'est de
tirer le meilleur profit
individuellement et collectivement de
mes joueurs mais je peux vous garantir
qu'on jouera en tant qu'équipe c'est mon
travail
c'est ma première fonction en tant
qu'entraîneur
et nous avons été rejoints en plateau
par notre consultant cyclisme Yann
dujariet bonsoir bonsoir alors avec vous
on va décrypter le parcours de ses
épreuves cyclisme de jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 le parcours a été dévoilé
hier ce sera dans quelques instants mais
avant on va continuer de parler football
l'as Poissy n'a pas réussi à convaincre
hier la commission d'appel de la ADN CG
la direction nationale du contrôle de
gestion de la Fédération le club
yvelinois donc officiellement exclu des
championnats nationaux pour en parler
avec nous le président du club Olivier
sevesuc alors cette décision elle a été
prise parce que le club est endetté
d'environ 280 000 euros et malgré
l'arrivée d'un sponsor ce que vous nous
deviez en début d'émission qui était
prêt à injecter 220 000 euros ça n'a pas
convaincu Olivier c'est vésu écoutez
c'était très surprenant
l'explication de l'adncg que je connais
bien parce que vous avez deux passages
par an depuis 6 ans donc vous pouvez
voir qu'on se connaît assez là c'était
une cour d'appel el un peu plus
difficile
qu'on appelle une j'avais pardon c'est
pas une cour d'appel c'est si une cour
d'appel puisque c'est un appel pardon et
j'étais venu avec les garanties d'un
chèque de 220 000 comme il y avait des
réserves on arrivait je l'ai expliqué en
début à l'équilibre donc j'étais content
confiant cabinet d'avocats un
représentant de cette société pourquoi
ça n'a pas convain selon vous allez
savoir je me pose aucune question
simplement on m'a demandé et j'ai
travaillé jour et nuit sans rien dire à
personne sur trois dossiers certains que
j'ai présenté j'ai essayé de présenter à
la mairie bon visiblement c'était
compliqué et celui-là je l'ai gardé pour
moi en me disant on fait les choses
nécessairesment c'est-à-dire que ce
chèque il était au nom de cette fois-ci
à la condition suspensive et c'est
normal c'était de dire que si le club
restait en N2 voir en N3 on débloqué le
chèque le lendemain j'ai le document
j'aurais présenté le document le chèque
je l'avais dans les mains
c'était gagné c'est l'incompréhension
qui domine aujourd'hui
les efforts que j'ai pu faire je suis
pas là pour parler de moi c'est fini
maintenant ce temps là j'étais prêt à
passer la main les joueurs les joueurs
malheureusement je les ai gardés sous le
coude en corrélation avec l'entraîneur
en disant pas on a un projet mais
attendez un petit peu tu es difficile
parce que les joueurs certains se sont
leur métier ce sont des fédéraux c'est
ce qu'elle a dit la difficulté qu'il y a
entre le monde amateur avec 42
éducateurs 700 licenciés et des seniors
dans l'équipe première l'équipe phare
l'équipe fanion où il y a des joueurs
qui sont rémunérés normal avec des
salaires mais chez nous vous savez
c'était le 9e budget de du groupe quand
même donc on n'a jamais été très très
loin parce que depuis que je suis là on
a augmenté même quand il y avait
Monsieur Laurent Fournier on était
pratiquement à l'équilibre sur ce qu'on
avait fait depuis de nombreuses années
malheureusement des paramètres des
sponsors qui s'en vont quatre choses
34000 pénalités de la fédé je me suis
expliqué en disant voilà obligé ce
chèque je sais que vous êtes humain
avant tout vous êtes la fédération mais
vous êtes là pour nous aider mon amateur
vous le dites partout tout le monde crie
d'être abandonné par la Fédération
je me pose la question de savoir si je
vais saisir le CNOSF et le tas parce que
c'est mon honneur je viens de perdre mon
père je vais le enterrer j'étais venu
ici pour parler de lui l'Ukraine j'ai
l'impression que c'est j'en ai même
pratiquement effondré aujourd'hui RMC
pris d'émotion je viens juste de
l'enterrer et je me suis dit c'est
l'Ukraine ou quoi on veut tous nous tuer
je sais pas je comprends plus rien
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait quoi mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait de mal qu'il y a
un trou effectivement qui n'est pas
extraordinaire puisque même avec
l'avance de l'Amérique que je remercie
sur la première subvention on était à
280000 j'ai 220 80 000 de réserve on
repartait sur un projet une autre
bouture avec beaucoup moins de joueurs
donc les joueurs malheureusement on les
a un petit peu jusqu'à la fin
certains sont partis parce que les clubs
commencent l'entraînement vous l'avez vu
pour le PSG ce sont des professionnels
mais nous ce sont des semi pro donc
quelque part il faut qu'il fallait
reprendre quoi qu'il arrive il avait
perdu 80% des joueurs et là on a libéré
les je crois qu'on a libéré le dernier
qui qui était sous contrat donc on a
plus que maintenant deux CDD et j'ai
pris des mesures par rapport à ça pour
mettre malheureusement le club en
cessation de paiement qui n'est pas un
dépôt de bilan en espérant que la dette
qui n'est pas énorme il y a quelques
fournisseurs puissent être nivelée et
que je laisse le club certainement à
d'autres
pas forcément quelle est la suite là
aujourd'hui pour vous
j'avais sollicité à les gens de la
mairie on a fait on a eu des courriers
bon j'ai pas eu de nouvelles depuis une
petite semaine
voilà moi c'était je voulais une belle
surprise pour tout le monde je fais une
belle surprise pour ce club et partir
propre quoi en disant alors comme j'ai
vous savez en six ans d'ailleurs je
remercie Carl quand il dit à quelques
quelques mondes quelques gens qu'on
connaît ensemble dans le monde du
football le dire mais le président et la
servi le club certains sont servis j'ai
jamais pris une fiche d'essence pour les
déplacements à Saint-Malo tout le monde
le sait donc je suis confiant je suis
allé m'expliquer mais moi me retrouver
au tribunal judiciaire où j'ai peut-être
mis entre 70 et 80 000 de ma poche de ma
petite entreprise j'ai pas de
multinationale comme certains dans
football étant mieux pour eux moi j'ai
aucun salarié j'ai un auto-entrepreneur
de 74 ans qui veut pas lâcher on est
tous les deux pour gérer un entrepôt je
gère des événements etc je travaille
tout le temps mais j'aime ça c'est ma
vie c'est ma boîte comme mon club
c'était pareil donc je veux simplement
rétablir un petit peu tout ça remettre
parce que c'est mon honneur c'est celui
de mon père et puis je considère que
quand vous avez passé le mal versation
pourquoi on m'a laissé comme ça alors
que je pense que malheureusement alors
après c'est une succession de choses on
m'a demandé à MC aujourd'hui mais vous
en avez appris la mairie non vous en
avez appris non non
les élus de Poissy en général ce qui
vous ont soutenu en début juin vous nous
aviez dit que vous aviez une réunion
avec la vérité voici comment ça s'est
passé très bon rapport avec Monsieur car
l'olive s'il connaît il sait très bien
ce que j'ai fait dans la banlieue
j'étais président du Nila Courneuve
pendant 10 ans donc voilà j'ai eu cette
médaille du mérite pour m'occuper du
social il savait que j'ai mis des
actions pour le handicap pour les
féminines pour un tas de choses les
Ukrainiens il m'a suivi tout le temps il
a trouvé chez Miss club en avant et ça
n'en a parlé suffisamment parvenir
là-dessus parce que dès que je vous dise
c'est juste de la tristesse parce que là
c'est un mot tristesse il y a des
familles qui attendent je voudrais juste
poser une question vendredi au premier
adjoint au sport en disant Eric est-ce
que je peux inscrire des gens parce que
vous savez il faut mettre une somme elle
a fait des disques j'aurais dit hier
pour inscrire les licences on avance
l'argent on a l'impression que la fédé
il faut toujours gagner de l'argent
j'aimerais bien savoir leur compte au
lieu de m'aider de dire bon ben écoutez
on a téléphoné aujourd'hui on dit ah bon
c'est pas donc je dis Eric Roger il faut
bien que j'inscrive les les enfants qui
qui sachent que demain ils ont un club
le club ne peut pas mourir parce que le
président s'arrête je suis resté
jusqu'au bout tout le monde a
démissionné j'aurais pu démissionner
mais je suis tellement c'est même pas de
la fierté mais en l'occurrence je sais
ce que j'ai fait a été plutôt bon pour
les autres je suis dans la bienveillance
aujourd'hui
de Madame le Maire
elle me dit j'ai un projet alternatif il
m'avait donné une deadline comme si vous
savez si vous n'avez pas un projet je
l'avais ce projet effectivement je leur
ai dit j'ai reçu des gens ils sont pas
venus visiter les installations ce que
je comprends quel est le projet de la
mère de
courrier depuis maintenant 10 jours j'ai
aucune nouvelle de personne le dernier
essence avec le premier adjoint pour lui
dire dois-je inscrire les équipes il m'a
dit non ok donc j'inscris pas si je veux
ce soir je dis il y a plus de clubs de
Poissy il est pensé ça sonnement il en
liquidation judiciaire j'ai rien à
craindre sur un chef d'entreprise qui
quelqu'un très responsable depuis 30 ans
et quand je vois le centre
d'entraînement à côté du parrain à côté
à Poissy pour une élogation aujourd'hui
j'en ai gros sur la patate j'ai toujours
voulu et d'ailleurs j'ai bataillé pour
ça me dire les jeunes de laine 3
pourraient jouer chez nous j'ai toujours
pensé qui est j'ai quand même porté ses
couleurs j'étais au centre de formation
très jeune je suis abonné depuis 30 ans
j'ai envoyé une lettre à Monsieur
khalafi qu'il a sans doute pas eu pour
déjà lui dire voilà mais sans lui
demander de l'argent je suis pas comme
ça simplement bienvenue on pourrait
mettre un jour échanger avec vos
collaborateurs et vous parler de ce club
de Poissy que je fais vivre depuis deux
ans moi c'est que ça qui m'intéresse
c'est la bienveillance mais je pense que
des gens sont pas bienveillants comme
moi et je l'ai pris un peu
personnellement lors du décès de mon
papa je me suis dit mais après vous
savez comme je suis un fervent croyant à
mon humble niveau j'ai dit même le
Christ de toute façon son propre peuple
s'est retourné contre lui donc je suis
un peu crucifié quelque part je suis
laissé sur l'hôtel j'en ai gros sur la
patate mais j'ai aucune rancœur contre
personne
je suis tous les jours au téléphone la
nuit je dors plus c'est très compliqué
faut pas oublier que je suis bénévole
c'est à dire que si encore aujourd'hui
j'avais peur en disant mais olive ou
tchoupe parce que tout le monde
m'appelle chouette ça va être
compliqué les comptes là parce que tu as
pris de l'argent etc d'ailleurs tout le
monde le dit mon expert-comptable
qu'avec moi depuis 6 ans la commissaire
en compte il y a peut-être eu quelques
négligences d'ailleurs il y a eu des
choses incroyables des commandes de
choses
tout maintenant retracé mais si les
trois derniers mois j'ai été moins
présent mon père
pratiquement mort dans l'incendie il a
fait deux mois d’hôpital un mois
hospitalisé à la maison il a fallu que
je m'occupe de ça et j'avais d'autres
priorités et dès que son décès au milieu
c'est pas que ça m'a libéré mais c'est
la vie et derrière
j'ai repris contact avec ces
investisseurs qui m'avait laissé un
petit peu tranquille contenu de ma peine
et de mes obligations familiales et
voilà j'ai eu ce chèque j'étais vraiment
très heureux je j'étais face en disant
on se connaît toujours souriant en
pensant que ils allaient valider ce
chèque il était là c'est pas grave si
quelque part je sais même pas si c'est
piloté par qui que ce soit je l'envoie à
personne mais là elle a fait des je
trouve ne fait pas son rôle on va dire
de grand frère comme toutes ces
fédérations c'est pas normal j'allais
justement dire les fédé parce que c'est
excusez-moi ce que vous vous soulevez là
c'est pas un problème lié au football un
cookies c'est un problème général dans
le sport de toute façon les fédérations
ne sont là que pour prendre pognon et
derrière moi accompagné
ce matin mais la fédé quelque part
monsieur le Président
vous en pensez quoi je dis mais c'est
marrant parce que c'est comme dans la
vie effectivement l'amour fait partie de
la vie mais il y a eu ces histoires avec
monsieur le Président ça a été vite jugé
il était classé à la télé je crois qu'il
est encore à la télé je dis moi
personnellement quand j'ai une femme
j'ai du respect c'est tout ce que j'ai
dit mais c'est assez jean-là que je
demande de m'aider j'ai aujourd'hui à
RMC ça sera aussi relayé parce que c'est
dans le monde du sport j'ai vécu dans ce
milieu sportif Luis Fernandez m'a aidé
me soutient et me dit chou qu'on a
démarré au PSG ensemble tu es mon ami
que vous aviez pas du tout l'intention
de démissionner aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous y pensez de démissionner mais bien
évidemment pour laisser la place mais
j'espère à un projet alternatif c'est
tout ce que je souhaite moi derrière je
peux pas accrocher un poste de président
puis on pourrait être honnête ça fait un
an que certains nombre de clubs veulent
que j'ai avec eux et je peux vous le
dire certains le savent mais je ne
dirais pas les clubs mais j'ai continué
à espérer pourquoi il y avait aussi le
PSG pas pour moi mais pour la vitrine du
club tout ce que je voulais faire autour
de ce club c'est du bonheur je veux dire
je m'étais dit ça va être super bon
après il y a eu tout ce qui s'est passé
cette année monsieur le Président qui
est venu je crois je me suis bien
comporté avec les Ukrainiens je pense
que la ville a été en lumière je suis
venu sur mon plateau vous êtes déplacé
Michael est venu je pense que j'ai
essayé de faire en tout cas socialement
un certain nombre de choses et
sportivement maintenant je m'accroche
pas je vous en prie
merci d'être venu témoigner en plateau
je le rappelle vous êtes le président
toujours le président de l'AS Poissy le
club vient d'être exclu des championnats
nationaux et on suivra bien évidemment
la suite et l'avenir je l'espère du club
avec attention sur TV 78 pouvoir offrir
aux personnes âgées le plaisir de rouler
à vélo c'est l'objectif de l'association
à vélo sans âges installé à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines depuis 5 ans
grâce à deux triporteurs les bénévoles
peuvent promener les bénéficiaires
autour de leur domicile pour leur
permettre de maintenir le contact à
l'extérieur c'est le reportage de Julien
Leroy
alors vous asseyez alors vous mettez sur
le côté que vous voulez à droite ou à
gauche quand se remettre en selle
devient un rituel depuis 2018
l'association à vélo sans âge installée
sur Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines propose
aux personnes dépendantes des sorties
entre ville et nature grâce à deux
tricycles la trentaine de bénévoles
actifs se relaient pour donner à nos
aînés un goût de liberté objectif leur
permettre de garder le contact avec
l'extérieur et maintenir un lien social
l'intérêt de triporteur c'est que ça
casse la glace il y a pas besoin de
d'intermédiaires on est de plain-pied on
peut très facilement dire aux gens
bonjour et bien ils sont pas interloqués
ils répondent ils disent bonjour Avec
avec le sourire et on peut s'arrêter et
entamer une discussion attention je vais
klaxonner
je voulais pas vous écraser c'est pour
ça
au guidon de Félix Christian vient
plusieurs fois par mois pédaler pour les
personnes âgées de cet EHPAD situé à
Guyancourt ça motivation l'envie de
partager avec eux un moment privilégié
parfois la seule sortie de certains ça
me fait plaisir de d'offrir un peu de
bonheur au résidents je serai peut-être
content si dans plusieurs dizaines
d'années c'était moi qui était promené
par par des plus jeunes que moi donc
pendant que tu peux le faire je le
faisoit là c'est bien on a besoin de
sortir à l'extérieur pour vous pour pour
voir autre chose vous comprenez on est
quand même confiné pendant pendant un an
dans tout l'hiver dans l'établissement
des balades personnalisées s'adaptant à
la demande de chaque bénéficiaire une
bulle d'évasion pour profiter de
l'instant présent cheveux souvent il y a
des grands-mères elles fondent devant
les enfants donc on va plutôt au devant
des enfants au devant des écoles au
devant des des personnes avec des landau
bien il y a des personnes qui sont plus
sensibles à nature donc on va plutôt
soit voir les moutons voir les voir les
voir les jolis coins
l'ensemble moi j'étais 41 ans à Paris
depuis le 1er janvier dernier près de
550 adhérents ont pu être transportés
par l'association 50 chinoise pour les
personnes à domicile une cotisation
annuelle de 15 euros et demander afin de
pouvoir rouler à volonté et retrouver
une seconde jeunesse
et un plateau nous avons été rejoint par
Virginie aneta bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes la responsable du pôle musique
actuel pour l'association l'usine à
chapeau dans quelques instants on
parlera avec vous de la grande soirée
d'été à la Bergerie Nationale mais en
attendant on continue de parler de sport
à moins de 400 jours du lancement des
jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 le
parcours officiel des épreuves de
cyclisme sur route a été dévoilé hier et
les 180 cyclistes passeront dans les
Yvelines le samedi 3 août pour les
hommes et le dimanche 4 août pour les
femmes alors pour décrypter ses épreuves
nous sommes avec Yann Dujarier notre
consultant cyclisme alors première
question ce parcours de 273 km pour les
hommes vous le trouvez comment de
manière générale j'ai deux analyses la
première c'est une déception parce que
j'aurais aimé que ce soit comme
d'habitude sur un sur des Jeux
Olympiques une boucle d'une 25 30 km que
les coureurs vont répéter de manière à
pouvoir les voir passer plusieurs fois
ça c'est ma première analyse à froid
quand j'ai quand j'ai su que ce serait
une grande boucle et puis hier on a vu
le parcours et là je me dis intéressant
pour deux choses première chose pour les
passionnés de vélo on pourra aller voir
à plusieurs endroits en se déplaçant de
manière très sur des très courtes
distances donc ça c'est aussi le côté
sympa de se dire bah je suis en vélo je
les vois à un point je fais 5 km ou 10
km je vais les voir à un autre point eux
hier part dans un sens je peux aller les
voir à un autre point où je le fais en
voiture voilà il y aura moins de se
déplacer et ça c'est aussi le charme
qu'on peut avoir sur les classiques les
classiques belges donc voilà c'est des
choses qui sont connues par le monde du
cycliste passionné entre guillemets
ensuite mais quand on voit cette Grande
Boucle on se dit aussi que ben elle va
tous les Illinois vont quasiment voir
passer une épreuve des JO devant chez
eux et quand on sait la difficulté que
ça peut être pour avoir des billets pour
aller voir quoi que ce soit ben là on va
avoir une épreuve olympique gratuite
dans le département donc voilà j'ai
cette
ce double double vision de se dire bah
ouais en effet ça aurait été sympa de
les voir passer plusieurs fois et puis
donc du coup pour pour revenir aussi à
cette première étape c'est que si on
veut voir passer plusieurs fois il y
aura cette petite boucle sur la sur abus
de Montmartre qui sera spectaculaire
puisque ce sera la ce sera la fin et
c'est là que voilà ce sera la c'est là
que le feu d'artifice va se passer et
donc je pense que ça va rendre et ça va
être une très belle course donc en fait
avec leur tulle maintenant qu'on l'a vu
ben oui finalement on va avoir un petit
peu de tout ça et ce parcours il est il
est hyper intéressant justement il
s'agit de la plus longue course de
l'histoire des Jeux Olympiques quels
seront les difficultés sur ce
parcourses
[Musique]
pour la France d'ailleurs c'est ça donc
c'est impossible de cadenasser la course
comme on peut le voir sur un tour de
France en ce moment vous ne pouvez pas
voir une équipe qui va contrôler la
course pendant 270 km donc et ben oui il
va y avoir plein de surprises pendant
cette pendant cette épreuve bien sûr que
il va y avoir les 150 premiers
kilomètres ou peut-être les 200 premiers
kilomètres qui vont être un peu longues
ou il y aura pas spécial pas peut-être
pas trop de spectacles mais il va se
passer des choses on va et on peut déjà
le dire aujourd'hui on aura un très beau
champion un très beau champion olympique
puisque en plus l'arrivée se fait au
pilotes juste devant le Trocadéro ça va
être ça va être vraiment très très très
sympa alors dans les Yvelines ils vont
passer par la vallée de Chevreuse c'est
un endroit apprécié par par les
cyclistes et par les coureurs
professionnels aussi alors
oui beaucoup moins par les habitants le
dimanche matin voilà moi comme je quand
je rencontre des gens qui habitent dans
la vallée de Chevreuse je leur dis
excusez-moi je te fais partie des
cyclistes que vous pouvez croiser
détester le dimanche matin oui
pas du tout beaucoup trop long surtout
qu'on puisse moi je ne je ne roule
quasiment plus je me suis mis à la
course à pied depuis un peu plus d'un an
et donc le vélo est devenu est devenu un
un vrai loisir entre voilà un vrai
loisir familial ce qui n'était pas le
cas pas le cas avant donc non non je
vous testerai pas 270 km c'est pas du
tout ma tasse de thé mais voilà ouais
non ça va être ça va être super sympa en
effet là les les côtes qui juste un
regret sur les côtes j'aurais aimé qu'il
prenne la côte de la Madeleine de
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse qui pour moi
est une des plus difficiles de du
secteur là là en effet ça va être ça va
être sympa mais pour des champions ça
fera pas des côtes ça varie entre 5, 3%
et
6,3%, ça va faire mal dans les jambes à
avoir votre visage j'ai pas trop
l'impression c'est c'est les kilomètres
qui vont qui vont faire qui vont faire
qui vont faire leur qui vont faire leur
travail et puis en effet la répétition
et trois fois
dans un circuit activement court je sais
pas combien combien il fait le circuit
j'avais pas j'ai pas j'ai pas trouvé
d'information j'ai pas pris le temps de
la chercher mais voilà la répétition sur
une courte durée après déjà 250 bornes
dans les dans les dans les jambes oui là
et là ça va faire exploser et ça va être
le feu d'artifice comme on l'a dit comme
on l'a dit tout à l'heure maintenant les
bosses de la Vallée de Chevreuse elles
vont être passées comme un grand
souvenir quand on avait vu Gilbert du
Clos la salle prendre une musette en bas
des 17 tournants et monter la côte sans
les mains et prendre ce qu'il y avait
dans la nuisette pendant toute la côte
voilà c'est des pros voilà ils sont sur
sur le Tour de France en ce moment ils
attaques d'école donc oui nos petites
côtes de la même chose
quand on regarde sur Strava après des
Paris Nice bah voilà les premiers de
chaque côte de chaque segment bah c'est
que c'est que eux c'est l'application
communautaire pour les sportifs pas que
pour pas que pour le vélo mais voilà
ouais quand on regarde les King of
mountain il y a que des pros parce que
ils sont tous passés par là sur des
Paris Nice sur des épreuves de de Tour
de France ou là il se promène
généralement mais ouais sur Paris Nice
ça rigole beaucoup moins et en effet il
y a beaucoup de beaucoup de segments où
on peut se comparer à eux
ou un profil type favoris pour pour les
JO alors le problème c'est que je suis
trop Chauvin pour pouvoir donner un
étranger donc je vais pas mouiller je ne
t'aurais pas donné un favori étranger
c'est pas du tout je ne peux pas
concevoir une course ou ce n'est pas un
Français qui qui gagne au départ donc je
ne serai pas
ouais ce serait pas juste comme comme
j'ai vu mon jugement ne serait pas bon
donc ouais j'espère que ce sera un
Français qui gagnera
on est beaucoup trop loin de toute façon
pour pouvoir avoir des informations là
il y a plus d'un an qui va s’écouler
d'ici là il y a trop de choses qui
peuvent qui peuvent se passer dans la
carrière de beaucoup de ces cyclistes et
des cyclistes mais ce sera de toute
façon un très beau champion c'est sûr
alors on va parler du parcours des
femmes 158 km là aussi quel est votre
ressenti par rapport à ce parcours ça va
être dur ça va être dur parce que autant
les garçons ont des courses tout au long
de l'année qui font cette distance là
alors que les filles beaucoup moins
généralement Championnat du Monde c'est
120 km un championnat de France c'est
120 km là on va les taper 150 170 bornes
donc avec des encore une fois petites
équipes donc mesdames là va falloir
s'accrocher alors le problème du
cyclisme féminin c'est qu'il y a moins
de densité et là par contre en effet
alors oui pareil même pour aller
chercher une Française ça va être très
très compliqué mais on est à un an et
c'est vrai que ce sera de toute façon
une une grande championne qui gagnera
aussi parce que la sonde la boucle à la
ce sera la même je sais pas si elle
l'affront trois fois ou pas mais de
toute façon ça fera ce sera le juge de
paix et ce sera ça ne pourra être qu'une
grande championne qui gagne aussi le
titre olympique chez les femmes est-ce
que vous avez en tête un endroit un lieu
pour justement bien voir cette épreuve
de jeux olympiques dans les Yvelines
dans les Yvelines alors oui j'ai vu sur
la carte il y avait il y avait un
endroit ça fait un peu ça fait un peu
une étoile et c'est vrai que il y a un
endroit où on pourra aller les voir deux
fois vraiment très très simple il doit y
avoir 10 km grand max entre le entre les
deux points je crois que c'est la plaine
de Versailles et puis un moment ils
reviennent sur 50 ans en Yvelines donc
voilà ça doit être ça doit être à
l'écran voilà ça doit être à peu près là
mais là c'est un peu loin pour moi plein
bah oui donc l'anniversaire il passe
même deux fois donc donc voilà il y a
quand même pas mal d'endroits où on peut
aller se promener et les voir passer à
plusieurs endroits après les bosses de
la Vallée de Chevreuse ouais c'est ça va
être ça va être ça va être sympa surtout
qu'on sera sur la dernier tiers du
dernier tiers du parcours il y aura
quand même eu des kilomètres qu'on qu'on
peut y avoir surtout aujourd'hui en plus
avec les coureurs pro qu'on a
dynéité une course à 70 bornes de
l'arrivée ils sont capables de le faire
là je pense à des vins de poules des
pogacchard ils sont capables parce
qu'ils ont pas l'équipe surtout pas cher
de de dire ben moi je vais jouer ma
carte à 70 bandes je vais surprendre et
vous viendrez pas me chercher donc même
dans La Valette Chevreuse en effet il y
aura des rampes qui pourraient servir à
quand on va enchaîner saint-rémie les
cheveux et châteaux fort derrière si
c'est enchaîné un très très bon rythme
ça peut faire ça peut faire très très
mal et bien merci beaucoup Morgane
duvier pour toutes ces précisions alors
outre les épreuves de cyclisme sur route
le département accueillera également le
VTT sur la colline d'Élancourt le golf à
Guyancourt le cyclisme sur piste et le
BMX au Vélodrome Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ou encore
l'équitation au château de Versailles et
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour vous dire
que de nouvelles places ont été mises en
vente à partir de ce matin 3 millions de
billets sont accessibles sur le site
officiel de la billetterie c'est jusqu'à
épuisement des stocks allez maintenant
on va ouvrir une petite page culture et
loisirs
[Musique]
ce samedi 8 juillet la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet organise sa
grande soirée d'été pour en parler avec
nous Elisabeth les squat la directrice
et Virginie aneta la responsable du pôle
musique actuel pour l'association
l'usine à chapeau alors l'événement
commence à 15h quel est le programme
donc l'événement va commencer à 15h sur
site par contre il commencera vraiment à
14h30 par une balade théâtrale dans le
cadre de jardin ouvert une opération du
conseil de la région et de France Merci
par l'accompagner Hadès donc ça ça va
être vraiment un parcours à suivre en
famille
voilà et du coup il viendront faire un
petit peu un final au jardin de
Montorgueil à 15h d'accord ensuite on
aura donc des animations ludiques un peu
pour toute la famille donc avec des jeux
qu'on initier noix d'usinage chapeau le
troll Farmer c'est entre l'escrime et le
rugby en fait c'est adapté aux enfants à
partir de 6 ans enfin voilà on court on
s'amuse on est déguisé voilà alors
comment on conjugue l'escrime au rugby
ça se passe comment alors on a des
frites d'accord et puis on se jette les
uns sur les autres et voilà non c'est
plutôt vraiment très ludique on aura
aussi notre ludothèque itinérante la
Ludo mobile qui qui se mettra sur le
jardin de Montorgueil pareil avec un
espace dédié au plus petit avec des jeux
et aussi pour toute la famille un
atelier création de lanterne on pourrait
faire voler après voilà et puis toute
une valorisation des pratiques amateurs
qu'on promeut à l'usine à chapeau avec
nos ateliers chants qui vont faire un
spectacle participatif avec le public
donc faire chanter le public avec notre
atelier musique actuelle et
en partenariat avec l'école de musique
de son champ qui va faire jouer son
atelier pop rock voilà on a une deuxième
balade qui sera plutôt à la musicale sur
le domaine de la bergerie avec la
compagnie des armoires pleines qui ont
fait des ateliers de construction de
cabane sonore toute la semaine avec des
jeunes qui qui rénovent un peu la
bergerie c'est quoi une cabane sonore
alors ça c'est à découvrir
c'est une sorte d'instrument qui fait
des sons qui sont pris un peu partout
dans la nature et notamment sur le sur
la balade et voilà et donc ça c'est
orchestré donc par la compagnie des
armoires pleines
et du coup il travaille avec un
architecte et un paysagiste et des
musiciens voilà alors à partir de 18h
vous programmez des animations dans la
cour royale ce sera quoi des concerts de
la danse alors essentiellement des et
voilà et l'idée c'est vraiment de mettre
en valeur le patrimoine en fait de la
Bergerie Nationale et en particulier le
patrimoine bâti puisque la cour royale
c'est une cour qui a été construite sous
Louis XVI en 1784 et avec un emblème qui
est le pigeonnier et comme tout il faut
les rénover c'est tous ces beaux
bâtiments historiques et l'idée c'est
vraiment de mettre en valeur le
patrimoine de la Bergerie Nationale et
du et celui aussi du domaine de
Rambouillet que ce soit le patrimoine
naturel comme on parlait là des oiseaux
du parc de la végétation mais aussi le
patrimoine boity et tous les bénéfices
de la soirée en fait sont reversés au
profit de la rénovation du Colombier
alors ce sera qui en concert voilà
plutôt la partie cuisine à chapeau
puisque nous on est une scène de musique
actuelle donc la belle d'État donc du
ministère de la Culture
donc on va on va proposer notre fanfare
de l'usine à chapeau qui est composé de
bénévoles et de musiciens plus
professionnels voilà en ouverture de la
soirée et puis après un groupe qui
s'appelle dim purple mémorial qui est
plutôt
mento rockstedis Saul vraiment très
ensoleillé dansant et pour l'été
exactement bah ça vous les vacances
enfin c'est le 1er jour des vacances
donc voilà et on finit par un groupe qui
s'appelle Why Not qui fait de la reprise
revisitée en fait on avait fait un bal
l'année dernière ça avait vraiment très
très bien marché l'idée c'est vraiment
de faire pour tout public en fait pour
un public très familial et pour venir
danser s'amuser ensemble
voilà c'est un rendez-vous plutôt
familial vous attendez combien de
personnes environ alors l'année dernière
on avait eu à peu près 3000 personnes
sur la soirée la journée du la journée
du samedi et évidemment pour pouvoir
danser écouter de la musique il y a
possibilité de se restaurer sur place
puisque c'est des buvettes avec les
produits de la Bergerie Nationale parce
que sur la Bergerie Nationale il y a une
exploitation agricole en agriculture bio
et donc il y a possibilité de consommer
des produits de la Bergerie Nationale
des yaourts de charcuterie du fromage
mais aussi des produits locaux type
bière ou autre ça vous donne envie d'y
aller faire du varier la même chose à
Palaiseau
plage en ce moment mais en effet c'est
des événements où il faut participer
parce que c'est local parce que c'est
très difficile à organiser dans ces
périodes compliquées donc bah oui dès
qu'il y a quelque chose à proximité moi
je suis jamais mes enfants et je leur
fais je leur montre que la vie en
collectivité est hyper hyper
intéressante et importante
guinguette aussi à la Bergerie Nationale
et donc vous allez accueillir les
inséparables Piou Piou pourquoi en fait
pour préparer festival et cette soirée
enfin la journée du samedi qui ouvre les
vacances et qui le point final il y a
des en fait il y a des soirées tous les
jeudis soirs du mois de juin type soir
et guinguette ou donc ça se passe dans
le jardin de mon corps de Montorgueil
qui est un jardin aménagé avec des
parcours pieds nus et avec une petite
scène donc il y a un groupe je choisis
par l'usine à chapeau qui qui joue de la
musique de à peu près 20 heures à 22h
22h30 et puis possibilité pareil entrée
gratuite et possibilité de se restaurer
sur place et depuis là le 1er jeudi du
mois de juin sans compter demain soir on
a déjà accueilli plus de 3600 personnes
donc et vraiment une ambiance familiale
festive apprécié de tout ça
je trouve que tous ces événements
aujourd'hui on est presque noyé et on a
du mal à avoir les informations de tous
ces de tous ces petits événements qui
peuvent y avoir proches de à proximité
de chez nous et des fois on a la
formation après et c'est c'est souvent
c'est souvent dommage parce que quand on
peut avoir l'information en amont et
qu'on y va on passe toujours des bons
moments alors justement on va prendre de
l'avance parce que pour les grandes
vacances de cet été vous avez aussi de
nombreuses animations pour les plus
jeunes alors sur la Bergerie Nationale
donc il y a une exploitation agricole
mais c'est aussi une ferme pédagogique
donc qui est ouvert au public et en
particulier aux jeunes enfants pendant
toutes les vacances scolaires et pour
préparer les Jeux Olympiques nous on a
une bergerie au vin pics
avec l'organisation de toute une série
de
d'épreuves un peu dans l'esprit
olympique avec pour les plus jeunes oui
par exemple ou tirer à la charrette à la
place d'un cheval voilà ce genre ce
genre de choses et avec une petite
remise de médailles à la fin pour pour
les enfants qui participent à arrêter
donc ça fait passer une bonne voilà non
non personne ne gagne chez vous
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde participe
en récompense tous les participants eh
la valeur n'est pas la même et
aujourd'hui en France et bien que vous
soyez médaillé de bons résultats
d'or vous avez entre guillemets la même
visibilité la même récompense je suis
désolé un médaillé d'or c'est pas le
même travail et c'est pas la même
récompense
en tout cas nous l'idée c'est de
proposer une demi-journée festive à la
Bergerie Nationale en profitant des
glaces et yaourts
et Virginie aneta d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau alors pour rappel
la grande soirée d'été c'est ce samedi 8
juillet à partir de 15h ou 14h30 à la
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet et
l'entrée est libre et gratuite de la
musique également à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines depuis 20 ans
la pmsq l'association pour la promotion
de la musique à 50 ans en Yvelines œuvre
pour la démocratisation du classique
chaque année à l'organise l'opéra des
enfants avec les élèves des écoles
élémentaires samedi dernier ils ont
livré au spectateur leur performance
après des mois de travail Julien Leroy
s'est rendu au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour assister
au spectacle
[Musique]
Dogora la puissante oeuvre d'Etienne
Perruchon interprété par les jeunes de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
[Musique]
les élèves des classes de la communauté
d'agglomération ont fait raisonner le
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
samedi 1er juillet une consécration pour
les jeunes chanteurs c'était bien on a
et ils ont créé une bonne expérience
c'était ma première expérience et
c'était la meilleure ils ont bien créé
le spectacle on a bien chanté
il y avait des moments lorsque j'aimais
trop parce que en répétition il y avait
pas tout le monde et là ça m'a avec tout
le monde c'était magnifique ce concert
était le fruit de longs mois de travail
et de préparation réalisée avec
l'Association pour la musique à
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines l'occasion
pour les enfants de présenter leur
performance à leurs proches oui je suis
trop fière de ma fille et c'était ma
première expérience avec elle et ça me
donnait trop de fierté et ça me fait les
langues dans les yeux là je suis trop
fière d'elle et merci pour l'école déjà
et pour toute l'équipe qui a participé
pour réussir cette événement et l'opéra
des enfants est organisée depuis 2003
par la pmsq le but de l'association
rendre accessible la musique classique
au population des quartiers défavorisés
un événement dont tout le monde ressort
gagnant un concert comme ça c'est une
fierté pour tout le monde et surtout
pour les enfants et pour leur famille
parce qu'on a des familles qui vont
rarement dans des salles de spectacles
et là les parents viennent ils sont
émerveillés parce que font leurs enfants
et ils sont justement émerveillés parce
que c'est des choses qui méritent le
respect c'est absolument incroyable les
enfants donnent donnent de même ils sont
complètement investis dans le dans leur
champ et c'est absolument phénoménal un
moment hors du temps ça lui est par un
tonnerre d'applaudissements pari réussi
pour les jeunes chanteurs de 50 ans en
Yvelines
elle est comme chaque mercredi c'est
l'heure à présent de passer à notre page
cinéma dans votre 7 8
[Musique]
vous vous trouvez un blasme hexagone oui
mon fils il dit toujours hexagone je
vais faire hexagone
à noter que yo Mama est inspiré d'une
histoire vraie celle d'enfant d'une
dizaine d'années qui ont joué dans un
clip de rap avec des liasses de billets
et des armes à la main en janvier 2015 à
Sarcelles vous nous proposez un autre
rendez-vous Céline avec le film une nuit
qui nous propose de déambuler dans le
temps d'une nuit dans les rues de Paris
oui Mathilde en compagnie de deux
étrangers qui nous invitent à passer une
nuit blanche avec eux une nuit c'est
l'histoire d'un coup de foudre à Paris
qui commence en début de soirée et se
termine au lever du soleil dans un connu
se rencontrent dans le métro puis passe
le reste de la nuit comme dose
adolescents à vagabonder ce chamailler
refaire le monde et philosopher sur la
vie et le couple et ce malheureusement
jusqu'à ce que le jour les rattrape
marier tous les deux ils savent que leur
histoire d'amour passionnelle n'a que
quelques heures de vie c'est Karine
Viard et Alex Lutz qui tiennent le rôle
des deux amants regardez
parfois tu mesures le bonheur arriver un
réparer quelque chose qui t'a toujours
résisté des moments de communication où
l'harmonie est parfaite
pourquoi en général à votre mari j'en
veux pas être pas là ce soir pour rien
vous savez qu'on va pas pouvoir se
revoir
comment je vais avoir du courage
avec ce nouveau premier bonjour
[Musique]
et on termine votre sélection Céline par
un film d'animation tout à fait
miraculous le film c'est l'adaptation
cinématographique et musicale de la
célèbre série pour enfants on retrouve
Marinette alias ladybug et Adrien dit
chat noir ils sont collégiens le jour et
super héros la nuit et combatte ensemble
les forces du mal sans pour autant
connaître leur véritable identité ni
leurs sentiments réciproque dans ce film
on parle surtout de l'origine des deux
super-héros super-héros et de leur
alliance pour affronter le papillon et
sa horde de super vilain à noter
également Mathilde que 21 ans et demi
après sa sortie initiale le cultissime
Astérix et Obélix mission Cléopâtre
Cléopâtre d'Alain Chabat ressort en
salle à partir d'aujourd'hui il sera
accessible partout en France en version
totalement restaurée et sera au tarif
unique de 5 euros ah oui 5 euros c'est
intéressant effectivement c'est
intéressant le prix des placements merci
beaucoup Céline Charles je vous propose
de continuer cette page cinéma avec le
coup de cœur d'un professionnel du
septième heure cette semaine c'est le
réalisateur yvelinois Benjamin pallier
qui nous parle de Seven le fameux
policier avec Brad Pitt et Morgan
Freeman
[Musique]
bonjour à tous cette semaine je vais
vous parler du film seven réalisé par
David Fincher en 1995 avec comme acteur
principaux Brad Pitt Morgan Freeman ou
encore Kevin Spacey l'histoire du film
c'est deux policiers qui sont en charge
d'une enquête sur un tueur psychopathe
qui planifie ses meurtres en fonction
des sept péchés capitaux il y a 7 péchés
capitaux la gourmandise
on touche arrière
sur les langues
le demeure très faut s'attendre à ça le
film a rencontré un grand succès en
salle puisqu'il accumulé parce que 5
millions d'entrées en France moi ce que
je trouve très intéressant dans ce film
c'est la mise en scène parce que David
Fincher a réussi grâce à ce film imposé
sa mise en scène notamment par rapport
au temps qui se passe dans le film c'est
à dire que la pluie est omniprésente
dans le film ensuite la couleur est très
terne et très contrastée ce qui donne un
côté très glauque au film le film est à
des scènes qui sont très
impressionnantes qui peuvent être très
choquantes après ordre
probablement un autre missile ils sont
victimes d'un jeu
aucune empreinte aucun témoin d'aucune
sorte c'est reparti la seule chose que
nous connaissons à son sujet c'est qu'il
est fou à lui ou le prix du péché
et la mort je vous conseille vraiment
d'aller le voir parce que ça peut être
très intéressant notamment de la mise en
scène
[Musique]
et c'est bien Tao la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant de se quitter
je vous propose de jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil aux prévisions météo de demain
matin météo France prévoit un grand
soleil dans les Yvelines au niveau des
températures il fera 14 degrés à
Rambouillet et Houdan 15 à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 16 à Versailles dans
l'après-midi le soleil sera toujours au
rendez-vous et côté température il fera
24 degrés en moyenne et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci pour votre fidélité
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV
78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]